yes let's jump into this first story we
have this one from timcast.com second
high altitude object shot down over
Alaska President Biden reportedly
ordered the military to down the object
out of an abundance of caution and at
the recommendation of the Pentagon
President Biden ordered it to shoot down
the object on February 9th North
American Aerospace Defense command
detected an object on ground radar on
ground radar and further investigated
and identified the object using fighter
aircraft a recovery operation is
currently underway conducted by United
States Northern command according to
Ryder who noted no further details will
were available regarding a description
of the object's capability design
purpose or origin that makes it a UFO
as far as I'm concerned and that story
sounds a lot better so here's where it
happened
seemingly off in the middle of nowhere
in northern Alaska
where the
first balloon should have been shot down
immediately
but uh
I don't know I think it's pretty obvious
that the the quickness with which they
shut this one down had you know was
probably because of the criticism they
received for about the first one yeah
but and Congress just passed the
resolution saying anything that comes in
d u s airspace needs to be uh dealt with
basically effectively immediately and
that was the unanimous vote in the house
what two days ago apparently it's the
size of a small car
I don't look we don't have a lot of
information on this stuff but um I mean
I'm I'm kind of happy they shot it down
I would agree all right we're all in
agreement that's that was great that's
the show for tonight everybody they shot
it down uh I think one of the
interesting details here is that how
they leave out the place of origin I
believe they know where it came from but
I think they're not mentioning it where
it came from for a reason and I think
that reason is is that if you don't say
what country likely China that it came
from China doesn't really have to
retaliate because then we technically
didn't shoot they didn't claim
responsibility for what it is so I'm
reading into the details a little bit um
here in between the lines I know that's
a little bit of Reckless speculation but
where this came from matters we
obviously just had the balloon incident
with China and I think there's a reason
they're leaving out some details did
anyone I don't I didn't I mentioned this
earlier did did you hear about the laser
that went across Hawaii the laser there
was a green laser that was it yeah yeah
someone they said that it was a SAT
likeliest satellite a Chinese satellite
and uh I didn't mention it earlier oh
yeah look at this what is that these
Green Lasers and it moves fast you're
telling me that's China I think it's
aliens whoa I mean
it's Russia it's Russia guys Matrix
coach Chinese aliens it is code the
simulation's breaking down and that is
the code well I mean I don't want to
derail but when I jokingly tweeted that
all of this infighting in the alt media
space was part of a plan people were
like really because it's so hard to
believe it's coincidental and I'm like
nah we're in a simulation everything's
falling apart no but uh that laser
thing's crazy what is this I kind of
feel like this needs its own segment we
can talk about it let's go back to the
to the object over all over Alaska
because my concern with this is as I
stated with the balloon
and I met now that we have a lot here as
well as well I'm interested in your
guys's opinions the way I described it
is like somebody's going to rob a liquor
store they don't care that having the
gun is illegal because they're about to
commit a much more serious crime China
doesn't care about balloons in our
airspace and if we get mad about it
because they're about to commit a much
more serious crime
Isabelle right yeah no that that makes
sense and maybe some people were not or
they're not saying where the origin of
it was from because a lot of people like
Fox News was getting criticized because
they were able to track the original
balloons like where it started in its
entire path so it's like well how did
you guys know and maybe they had someone
that's leaked a story or something but
so you guys knew where it was tracking
knew the its entire course but somehow
now we're just finding out about it
somehow people knew something and I just
missed when they were just making the
frogs gay as Alex Jones all they were
doing yeah that's I think they're trying
to make more frogs gay actually that's
why our kids are gay now I think that's
what the aliens the aliens are coming
yeah and you know and well so uh back in
all seriousness though uh world war
three a lot world war three I hope not
and uh you're gonna say I hope so no no
no I I hope not and I think again why
they're leaving out the place of origin
is allowing China to have like
permission not to retaliate because if
we say we shot down you know a Chinese
spycraft or whatever they will have to
respond one way or another either deny
or or not so they already condemned the
you know China you know made a stink
about
the shooting down the balloon which I
think was fairly ridiculous to to
imagine that they're in a position to
complain about it but
um I think that the the that makes a lot
of sense I'm not that not that I have
any kind of insight in information or
anything but it does make a lot of sense
the the giving China diplomatically a
way to not retaliate especially seeing
as they did comment on the first one if
it's like okay there's a second one
that's a clear escalation because they
have to respond if we publicly say this
is a Chinese uh you know aircraft that
we shot down they're gonna have to come
out with something and then we don't
want it to get into this sort of
escalatory ladder we're doing Tit for
Tat because I'm sure we have spycraft in
or around China and a lot of the
territories around them that they have
the potential to take down that you know
we don't want to get into that Tit for
Tat that would kind of be cool though if
like an American spy balloon flew over
China and then China shot it down and
then then like all of a sudden
everyone's doing this balloon conflict
where balloons are flying all over the
place I would prefer that to actual you
know nuclear conflict steampunk world
World War III nobody nobody wants to
escalate but this is these are the terms
we've set where everyone finds it
marginally acceptable like China sent a
balloon over we didn't shoot it down so
then everyone's like well I guess we can
send balloons and that's all people are
doing and it's like a balloon over my
country we need to get back to ping pong
diplomacy with China back in the good
old days what was the 80s um with Reagan
I think it was where we have like a ping
pong team go over and they like some
friendly sport matches instead of um
blowing up each other's balloons and
spycraft the NBA is in is pretty
involved with China so I'm not I'm not
100 sure that that's working out the way
that that ping pong did
ping pong I don't I don't know if we're
in the point of diplomacy so the one
thing the one reason I thought it'd be
great to have you on as well a lot is
that you've talked before about a
unipolar versus multi-polar world for
those that aren't familiar basically
should the US be the dominant force or
should there be multiple dominant forces
I'm kind of worried that uh yeah you
make a good point with unipolar
if the U.S falls from the top position
in terms of military power economic
power then the likelihood of conflict
increases this is thucydidity strap we
talk about it all the time
I don't know what the solution is though
man and and it seems like we're inching
towards a thucydides trap with China
which may be why there are some people
seemingly trying to sabotage the U.S so
that we fall before the conflict can
happen yeah I I think that there is a an
argument to be made that if there is
going to be a dominant power or or a
most powerful country in the uh or in
the in the world that it it's probably
better that it's the U.S not just
because we're here in the U.S but
because like liberal values and liberal
ideas do make space for people that
disagree and and you can expand that
whether it be regions or different
countries when you have a liberal order
versus what would be an authoritarian
order from China or from Russia like if
not that Russia's realistically going to
be a global power anytime soon they
don't have the economy but China could
be and it's probably better for the
world for the US to be the the the power
as opposed to if the option is the US
and China yeah and um to be fair this
doesn't mean that there aren't issues
within the United States like our
country has a ton of issues but I think
when you compare it to communist China
or authoritarian Russia or islamist Iran
there is no comparison there are some
people who say I've been seeing online
about how like Russia and China are
somehow like the saviors of the world or
or you know how zelenski's uh the
Antichrist or something I just think
there's a lot of crazy extreme rhetoric
going on and um we should double down on
our alliances worldwide that means
standing with Japan that means standing
with South Korea Taiwan doubling down on
what's going on in Ukraine every time
they have a successful or successfully
pushing back the Russians I think we
should double down on what's going on in
Ukraine and you weren't lying about that
mustache and for people who don't know
let me give you the rundown I'm sporting
a Bolton bro mustache right now I just I
know you guys are looking why is a lot
sporting this new mustache I'm trying to
follow in the footsteps of John Bolton
and you guys could join the movement you
guys could all do mustaches hashtag
Bolton bro on Twitter her with pictures
of your mustaches we can move on though
is that a real thing that like starting
tonight it is I mean there's one thing
about John Bolton um
that to them so they put hits on people
like John Bolton and if you are if
Ayatollah views you as one of the
biggest threats they're you're the
person who they're putting a hit on
there's something good about you I I
think there's you know we should have a
rally around the flag type when John
Bolton is being targeted by the
Ayatollah so are you gonna vote for him
for president uh I don't vote because
I'm a reporter I abstained I I don't
think there's any yeah for real though
yeah yeah I don't know how you can trust
any journalist who ever votes and that
goes from independent all the way up to
mainstream if you have it in the bag for
a candidate then how could anybody trust
you all journalists newsrooms literally
endorse candidates yeah and I think they
should abstain like I think that's
insane I disagree yeah I think they
should abstain and it's always a
Democrat like there's like three Outlets
that endorse Republicans even the right
wing Outlets start endorsing democrats
for example the New York Post endorsed
Eric Adams who's a Democrat is the New
York post supposed to be right wing
definitely yeah Murdoch owned yeah
definitely Harry Wang I did not know
that interesting yeah I think we have
some buddies there too but yeah I wonder
what the actual uh likelihood of of a
real International conflict is
they they they came out and said they
recently discovered that there are
balloons flying over the U.S during the
Trump Administration which no one saw no
one complained about and as far as I'm
concerned didn't happen it's like if a
tree falls down in the forest and nobody
hears it didn't make a sound it's like I
agree I don't I I think it's just making
stuff up yeah but the interesting point
is so what you bring up a lot is that if
we if they came out and said hey this
was China who did this again you'd have
people screaming some kind of sanctions
at the very least and then as you
pointed out you get to that escalation
but I don't also have the semiconductor
um supply chain war that we have going
on in China Joe Biden just had the chips
act and I think we banned all
um Americans from working in their um
semiconductor industry you guys should
look up an article and read more about
it but the chips Act is huge and and um
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only show was
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time